jeff bezos became the second billionaire
in outer space yesterday and the one to
make it
farthest out irritating it seems just
about every single person in the country
except for me i think it's terrific
with the way we blow cash in this
country on aimless wars
on open borders dr fauci funding the
wuhan laboratory and freebies from the
money printer
jeff bezos has every single right to
spend his wealth on an inspiring joyride
especially before inflation eats all
that money away if texas democrats can
take a mask-less
taxpayer-subsidized private jet booze
cruz to dc
then jeff bezos can slip the surly bonds
of earth
to touch the face of god i love the
bezos thing i think it's great everyone
is going after this guy even tulsi
gabbard
who's who's quite nice usually and talks
about the spirit of aloha
even she was making the joke that
everyone else was which is
hey bezos please stay up there do the
world a favor by the way i think
that that tweet tulsi sent out i bet
that was a staffer tweet
it's just not the right tone tulsi has a
certain tone
so i would guess that that was probably
a staffer but everyone else was making
the same point
stay up in space no one wants you you're
too powerful you
you control everything by the way
where's my latest amazon package i
ordered it
27 minutes ago why isn't it at my door
yet but yeah we hate you jeff bezos
i think it's it's a great way to spend
money
the big complaint that people are making
about jeff bezos spending
some untold millions of dollars on going
up into space for 15 minutes
is they say jeff you could have solved
poverty
you could have ended poverty but instead
you took a joyride and first of all jeff
bezos can't end poverty
because the poor will always be with you
we know that our very lord and savior
told us that so i think it's probably
true i think we can take that one to the
bank
second of all it's not as though jeff
bezos just blew his money
on some vanity project it's not as
though he just
blew his money on some silly
preposterous
only self-indulgent thing he spent his
money
on an inspiring activity
he spent his money on an actual human
achievement
to to explore the cosmos to slip the
surly bonds of earth
and to inaugurate an era of what very
possibly will be
commercial civilian space travel that's
great
i i like that among all the mundane
tedious awful things that we're debating
in our politics we can't even agree that
a man
is a man and a woman as a woman we're
talking about letting criminals out of
prison and all sorts of
just ugliness in our politics to see a
guy just shoot himself up into outer
space
with the implicit and i actually
explicit promise with these multiple
companies richard branson's
jeff bezos that other civilians we will
be able to go
into outer freaking space and look at
this beautiful creation of planet earth
that's wonderful i'm so glad
that he could do that the criticism of
bezos
spending his money this way reminds me
it's almost exactly the same
as the criticism of the catholic church
and i guess some other churches too it's
mostly the catholic church
for having really beautiful cathedrals
i'm sure you've heard the criticism
before they'll say
the catholic church has all this money
and what they're spending it on huh the
greatest works of art ever that glorify
god and bring truly sublime
and beautiful art to the common man
that when they're spending it on that
instead of some other like welfare
program or something that's awful that's
terrible
they should just cure poverty no you're
never going to cure poverty and
it is a wonderful thing for civilization
when wealthy individuals and wealthy
institutions
spend their money in a way that is
inspiring and uplifting
and gives glory to god and and even in
ways
that promote human achievement i think
that's a wonderful thing i can't believe
i've got to defend jeff bezos
you know that i'm not the biggest fan of
gigantic
multinational corporations and big
technology companies
but credit where credit is due i think
it's great i'm so
pleased that you liked that clip i am
i'm very happy now i want to help you by
letting you know
that there's a full episode that you can
watch it's called slipping the surly
bonds of earth
you can get it here on youtube ring the
bell subscribe comment you can get it on
apple podcast google play stitcher
spotify myspace
aol instant messenger hotmail i don't
know you can get it anywhere and you can
also get my book the number one national
best-selling speechless
controlling words controlling minds see
you next time
[Music]
you